okay well that's where we begin with the
midterms big names from both parties
they've been out on the campaign Trail
trying to sway opinions and as you can
tell there's a lot on the line tomorrow
so fortunately we have two of the best
in the business here with us today CBS
News Chief Washington correspondent
Major Garrett and CBS News election law
contributor David Becker joins us now
David's also executive director of the
center for election Innovation and
research good morning there's so much to
talk about major just set the table for
us where do things stand for the both
the parties right now so Democrats are
on defense and Republicans are on the
ascent and that's the psychology that
both parties feel right now we get this
guess what the voters are the in between
in that Ascent defense and the voters
will tell us exactly what they care
about and how much they care about
democracy it shows up on every poll
there's anxiety and curiosity how
resilient is our structure but if
Republicans win that doesn't mean
democracy is dead doesn't mean nobody
cares about it what it means is they
prioritize other things more which in a
democracy is your privilege if you say
inflation means more to me or Public
Safety slash crime in my neighborhoods
or someplace else or immigration and you
vote that way that's an expression of
your prioritization and there's nothing
wrong with that I think they care but is
that message Landing or resonating with
voters it doesn't seem to be at this
particular time
so the polling would indicate that
you're right Gail one thing that I think
is an X Factor in the polling is we saw
after the Dobbs decision this summer a
large number of young women in this
country register to vote for the first
time if you're polling and you're
looking for likely voters you're not
screening those because they're newly
registered they've not voted before
they're not going to be on your likely
voter screen if those registered new
voters show up that could be an X Factor
tomorrow night David a lot is being made
about the security of the 2020 election
now what should we expect when it comes
to Counting ballots now right so first
of all the 2020 election that we just
came from was the most secure
transparent verified scrutinized
election in America not everybody is
saying that that not everyone is but
it's just doesn't make any less true
yeah right right and 2022 is even more
so we've had over 40 million people vote
in convenience and safety already that
number is likely to grow in terms of
early and mail voting perhaps as high as
around 60 million we might have record
turnout for a midterms so election
officials have got this they're doing a
really good job people are going to find
that when they go to vote if they choose
to vote on Tuesday rather than having
voted early they're going to vote in
safety and convenience there might be
some lines that's normal we always have
not worry about security no not at all
the security of the system is really
intact now what happens after 8 PM is
that you know the the election officials
are going to be counting the ballots
okay it's going to take some time that's
always the way it's been it always takes
some time and particularly when we have
narrow margins we get a little antsy we
write we want to know what's going to
happen I want to know what happens but
let the election officials these are
your neighbors your community members
your fellow citizens let them do their
job we have very complex ballots in the
United States multiple Pages dozens of
races let them do their jobs it might
take a few days but many people are
raising the possibility of violence
actually at the polls and I think people
are scared you see people armed standing
there at their polls watching that's
scary stuff I think it's it's very
serious I'm sitting at home watching it
and I'm scared so the atmosphere feels a
little bit more tense there's no
question about that but to David's point
the early voting and much of it is in
person people are experiencing this in a
safe accessible way we want to emphasize
that that is for most Americans 99.9 of
all Americans that's how they're
experiencing this process and that's how
they are likely to experience it on
Tuesday but can local law enforcement
rule out the possibility of violence or
people interfering no they can't but
they're much more sensitized to this
than they were in 2020. and I should
just add really quickly I'm talking to
election officials all over the country
and they're very attuned to this they
are ready they're prepared they're
making sure one of their primary goals
is the safety of Voters as they go to
vote and I think voters are going to
find that that works for example real
quickly say there's a bomb threat at a
Precinct they have to close it down
they've already got a backup plan on
where to move it and how to adapt they
have really thought through this process
to be ready for on the unexpected David
the election deniers who are
participating in in this election can
you put them on a spectrum for us
because some of the election deniers
have sort of mumbled about the last
election that's all they've done others
have a plan in place to not only deny
the last election but deny the one
coming can you give us essential sense
of what that Continuum is like yeah sure
there are some who have basically just
kind of
paid some heed to the election denial
claims and said well we don't know for
sure who won I think there were problems
things like that that's bad enough
because it leads to doubts in the system
that people should feel secure about
right but there are clearly some who are
running on a platform of election denial
that the election was supposedly stolen
which of course it wasn't and that they
will act to try to put their thumb on
the scale for their own candidates in
future elections I mean we're hearing
from some of them that they can't
imagine that it's possible in a 50 50
country or 50 50 state for the other
side to win or that they don't know
anyone who voted for the other side
which probably says more about who
they're hanging out with and than
anything else so those are the kinds of
things we'll need to wash for if some of
those like rigid election deniers end up
winning and if they win what message
does that send what does that say about
this country
well I think you know one of the things
we're going to have to do is some
introspection after this election and to
try to figure out what democracy really
means to US democracy is the way we
resolve our disputes we have legitimate
policy disagreements in the United
States if we erode the guard rails of
democracy so that we no longer have that
framework to resolve our disputes we're
going to be in trouble as a democracy
Now president Trump has said that former
president Trump has said he's going to
have some very very very very very very
good news after this election what
impact we're all we're all taking that
to mean that he's going to announce he's
going to run there's every expectation
he will announce at some point one or
two weeks after this midterm election I
think it's earlier if the Republicans do
from their perspective better than
they're currently imagined to do I think
he gets in as fast as possible that'll
affect the vote tomorrow so I think I
know Republicans who I've talked to have
been like I wish we were not having this
wedge conversation about anticipating a
trump bid for re-election they want to
keep this on inflation Public Safety
immigration and the like and change not
have former president Trump in there but
of course he always decides for himself
and the default is more me less
Republican party Major Garrett David
Becker thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate you see you tomorrow night
yes indeed we will be here yeah all
night